[Music]
good day sal y jaramillo greets you with
your report of the day today monday
february 15 nevada is slowly
loosening coronavirus restrictions
starting today capacity limits
are now at 35% for most
businesses including restaurants now
6 people per table will be allowed and
reservations will now be waived capacity limit
increases to 50% for libraries museums and
aquariums public gatherings
may also increase to 100 people or 35
percent of site capacity
whichever less is anticipated
capacities will change again as
of march 15
the state of nevada is still at
the bottom of the
vaccine distribution list bloomberg analysis
reports that
at least 430,000 doses of
the vaccine have been administered since the past  December and
more than 10% of Nevadans have received
a dose and more than 3% have been
fully vaccinated unfortunately
these c  ifras put nevada in 48th
place on the list
also today the
number of capacity for churches and
places of prayer will increase from 35
percent to 50% according to information from
the governor's office this is due
to an order of the court of the ninth
circuit on restrictions for religious sites
now we move on with your
weather forecast a day with sun and clouds is expected
the maximum will be close to 65 degrees and
the minimum in the 40s for tomorrow
the wind will return  Good morning,
I am Sal and Jaramillo and this was from
Disney in Spanish
[Music]